as possibly the worst port and supply
chain crisis in america's history roils
the economy and threatens to continue
all the way through christmas and beyond
it is just now being reported that
transportation secretary pete bootage
has been on paternity leave for the past
two months
and has no plans of coming back to work
anytime soon
everything and i really mean everything
about this story is wrong sad and
ridiculous pete buddha judge
secretary of transportation
is missing an action
because he is on paternity leave
i got
in a lot of trouble over the weekend on
twitter because i made fun of pete
buddajedge's paternity leave and
i would say just about every
conservative is mocking
this incident the buddha judge paternity
leave but they're doing so with varying
degrees of breadth
meaning everyone is mocking the idea
that the transportation secretary just
disappeared a cabinet secretary
disappears for two months but there's
more
wrong to this story than just that all
right so i think there are three aspects
of this that are really really wrong the
first one we all agree on
no cabinet secretary should be able to
just disappear for two months for
paternity leave or any other reason and
if they do disappear for two months they
need to be replaced it's kind of funny
that
no one even noticed buddha judge was
gone frankly if he'd been around he'd
probably make things worse but no
cabinet secretary should be able to just
disappear for two months okay that's the
first thing that's wrong
the second aspect that's wrong with this
is more specific to buddha judge okay
there is this youtuber who goes by the
name
shuon head she said to me michael
i think you're just
secretly in opposition to gay marriage
and adoption
but you're just using paternity leave as
a way to hide that and clearly this
woman has never listened to my show
because i don't think i've been exactly
shy about my opposition to redefining
marriage but this does pose a real
issue here because
there are the only argument i've ever
heard that's even somewhat compelling
for paternity leave is it's not so much
for the dads to take care of the kids to
sit at home for a couple months and
change diapers and chest feet or
whatever it's so that the dads can take
care of mom
while mom recovers from the physical
trauma of
pregnancy and of childbirth
obviously in pete budaj's case he
doesn't have to worry about that because
there's no mom at home
and and so it does raise this issue of
the redefinition of marriage and the
family because there are two ways that
pete buddha judge could have acquired
these kids that he's now going to raise
and it's not clear he's been kind of
cagey on which one it is the first one
is adoption
and if these babies were adopted what
that means is that in a country where
there were 36 couples approximately
trying to adopt every one infant put up
for adoption
some adoption agency decided to deprive
these children of being raised by a
mother and a father and to choose to
have them raised by two men
and if you're fine with that
what you are saying is that there is
nothing that mothers add
to raising children there is nothing
that mothers uniquely or especially do
that fathers don't do there's no special
role for moms and for dads it's all just
the same
mom and dad are exactly the same they're
completely indistinguishable
and
i know that a lot of people pretend that
these days but i don't think very many
people actually believe that when you
think back to your childhood were mommy
and daddy exactly the same did they
fulfill exactly the same roles and
neither of them added something special
to your upbringing
bo they were just completely
interchangeable no no one really
believes that the other way that buddha
judge and his partner could have
acquired the kids
is even more morally dubious and that is
through
in vitro fertilization and surrogacy
and this is a process whereby a man will
choose a woman out of a catalog purchase
her eggs and then use the womb of
another woman to implant an embryo and
then get rid of the women altogether and
just just raise the kids
and this is more morally dubious because
it involves the intentional creation of
a baby for the express purpose of
denying him his natural mother which is
wrong it's a wrong thing to do babies
have a right to their mother a lot of
people think that if you're slowing down
throughout the day all you can do is
just have more and more caffeine just
another cup of coffee a tenth cup an
eleventh cup of coffee well i got a new
way to start your day to keep yourself
feeling good that would be super beets
heart chews a tasty treat that gives you
the energy you need and a treat that is
good for you no more afternoon coffees
energy drinks and candy for a quick
pick-me-up add two delicious plant-based
super beets heart chews to your morning
routine promote heart-healthy energy for
your day without a caffeine crash
the grape seed extract used in super
beets heart shoes has been clinically
shown to be two times as effective as
supporting normal blood pressure as a
healthy lifestyle alone a lot of people
over here at the daily wire have started
eating these super beets i got to hide
them so that people don't don't just
keep eating them because they're also
pretty tasty so they'll just like pop
them back like candies
i would strongly recommend that you
check out super beets heart shoes for
heart healthy energy
join over 1 million customers get free
shipping and returns a 90-day money back
guarantee and right now you get free
30-day supply with your first purchase
at superbeats.com
knowles that's superbeats.com
knowles i i don't want to seem like i'm
just beating up on bootage and his
partner here
i actually have a great deal of sympathy
for it i have even empathy for them okay
this is sort of a personal issue
in in the sense that when i got married
sweet little elise and i we are catholic
all right we started getting ready for
the baby machine right away and it
didn't happen right away and if you've
ever dealt with infertility problems of
any sort you know this is a very
painful thing it's very difficult and
i'm sure that buddha judge and his
partner
just have a natural longing to have a
kid
but they don't
have the desire or the willingness to do
the things that naturally lead to a kid
and so
i remember when we were trying to have a
kid you know my wife said
well oh gosh maybe we should do ivf
maybe we should do this maybe we should
do that catholic church does not permit
that because they're morally suspect
processes whereby multiple embryos are
created some are just put in a freezer
forever some are destroyed and it can be
a really
bioethically wrong process
and the conclusion that we came to is
that
yes it's good to have a kid that's a
good thing to want
but a good end does not justify immoral
means okay it's good that buddha judge
and his partner want kids that doesn't
justify
depriving that child of his natural
mother or of the opportunity to be
raised by a mother and a father okay so
that's the that's the part that a lot of
conservatives are probably not going to
say because they they don't want to seem
like they're being mean to bootage edge
and his partner but and no one wants to
be mean to them but it's just a fact and
one has to think about
the broader moral implications here and
one has to think about kids and one has
to think about what it means to have a
father and a mother and these sorts of
realities the third part that's
ridiculous about this story
and this is probably the least popular
opinion of all but it's true is
that paternity leave
is a very silly concept okay
it is it's a very modern silly concept
and i'm sure that there are many
listeners out there who took paternity
leave or who plan to take paternity
leave i do not begrudge you your
employment benefit
it's perfectly natural to take advantage
of all the benefits you can
but it's a silly thing it's a very new
thing there used to be such a thing as
maternity well there used to be such a
thing as mothers staying home and
raising their kids
then as more and more women enter the
workforce in the 20th century there was
such a thing as maternity leave because
mothers have a lot to do with their kids
when the baby's born one
the mothers have to recover from
pregnancy and childbirth
two they have to
breastfeed three they have to nurture
and bond and take care of this little
baby
fathers
don't really have to do that okay
they're actually matt walsh got in
trouble for saying this over the weekend
there actually isn't all that much to do
for
dads for their little babies when
they're born we're not gonna chest feed
okay we're not i guess we can change
some diapers or something but
it's
it's a little bizarre i think for men to
stay home for two months or more in the
case of bootage edge
to
change diapers or something i'm so glad
you enjoyed that clip i liked it too i
thought it was good
the way i said that thing about that it
was really good you can get the whole
show here at this youtube channel you
ring the bell you subscribe that's great
or you go to the michael knowles show at
apple podcast spotify stitcher google
play subscribe we really appreciate it
really helps us out to avoid some of the
big tech censorship issues
we'll see you over there and see you
next time
[Music]